to know what you think about our network
write to us at the c-span networks
400 north capital street suite 650
washington dc
2001
[Music]
[Applause]
up next on booknotes we examine the
history of the oil industry and its
effect on world politics and the economy
our guest is daniel jurgen author of the
prize the epic quest for oil money and
power
he discusses how the oil industry has
strengthened the power base of the oil
rich middle east and the role oil may
play in the current war in that region
[Music]
daniel jurgen author of the new book the
prize
do you think it was a mistake for us to
rely so
much on oil as our main energy source
it's a little late in the day to decide
it was a mistake i think that for the
most part oil has made possible
a very convenient
lifestyle and has made possible a a
whole
century's way of
doing things of living and so forth so
in general it made possible our modern
way of life
whether we should
have done it some other way would have
taken some foresight and some
alternative notions that weren't there
at the time 20 years from now we still
have the same reliance on it a decade
ago
i would have thought that this age of
oil would have ended more rapidly that
something after this
fall the shawn would happen with prices
that would move into a new era i think
having spent about seven years working
this book and thinking about it i now
come to the conclusion the problem this
age of oil is going to last longer than
we would have thought that it will
continue well into the 20th century
unless there is some major technological
change that we don't see now
that comes in as has happened repeatedly
in history and changes things and i
could be proved wrong tomorrow but my
sort of working hypothesis is that we're
in this for a while longer when did you
first get the idea of writing this book
i think it started in uh
really
about a decade ago
the first book i had done had been a
book on international relations the
narrative history of soviet american
relations the origins of the cold war
and so that was a fundamental interest
and then as i was finishing that book i
became quite obsessed with the issues of
of oil and international politics i did
a second book called energy future
which is
i remember the publisher wanted to drop
it because he said it was so boring no
one would want to read it it ended up
spending about nine weeks on the new
york times bestseller list because of
when it came out
and finally it seemed to me that the
natural thing to do was to combine
my love of writing and storytelling and
and the story of international politics
with this expertise that i've developed
in the oil and energy area and tell
the story that i've told in the prize
of course when i
set out to do it i had no idea what i
was getting myself into and if somebody
would said to me you're going to spend
seven years on this project i would have
said no way i guess just one other funny
thing that sort of ties into that
about 10 years ago when i was first
beginning to thinking of doing this book
another of the new york publishers came
to me and said um you know mr jurgen
would you like to write a history for us
for the 20th century
and i said you know uh come back in
about 30 years let's wait and see how it
comes out and so forth
but i now find that in a certain way
with the prize i've i've written a
history of the 20th century from a
particular perspective
looking for the number of pages 870
that that includes footnotes
could how long would this have been had
you gotten every word in that you had
written
originally well i originally wrote this
book longhand and it was originally a
2500 page manuscript because each
chapter became a little story in itself
and i knew that was totally unacceptable
i wasn't you know that much of a deluded
lunatic to think that the world was
waiting for that
so the went through a very tough process
of cutting it in uh half so it was about
1100 manuscript pages and the text is
now about 781 pages what did you leave
out
a wonderful anecdote
is it mostly anecdotal stories well
stories and analysis but uh
the detail you know it's
when you're writing a chapter
you see it in the chapter size
and then when you stand back and look at
the whole architecture of the book you
realize you go too much into that for
instance i went in much more detail
about how the saudi and kuwaiti oil was
originally discovered in the
negotiations leading up to that
and you realize that if you go into that
detail in the whole book readers will
get lost so i had to leave out
delightful details about
how the
emir of kuwait in 1934 was mad at the
british because the iraqis were taxing
his date gardens which were in southern
iraq and that was one reason that he was
interested in having an american oil
company come into
kuwait i've kept some of that in but
this whole wonderful negotiation over
the amir's date gardens a lot of that
ended up on the cutting room floor where
was oil first discovered
thousands of thousands of years ago
partly in the near east i mean oil was
used perhaps to bind the walls of
jericho
it's thought that moses's little basket
may have been caulked with bitumen
petroleum
and but it was in the 19th century that
we started to move into a modern period
and the real beginning of it goes back
to the middle of the 19th century
when a man named george bissell who's a
real founder of the world oil industry
who was a school teacher a lawyer a
journalist a
man who knew seven or eight languages
and a real entrepreneur he'd been
self-supporting since the age of 12
conceived this idea that this product
called rock oil which is uh
bubbled up of springs in western
pennsylvania could perhaps become an
illuminant that could be used to replace
the whale oil which had gone up to 2.50
cents a gallon
could provide most people didn't have
light at all at night
and he conceived the idea of drilling
for oil and hired the famous colonel
drake who wasn't a colonel
and what they really did in 1859 was
proved the supply of oil
but there was a supply of oil by showing
that there would be ample supply that
you could drill forward and obtain it
and that instigated the first oil boom
set the oil industry off and for the
first 40 years the oil business was an
illumination business kerosene was its
main product john d rockefeller became
the richest man in america selling
illumination
how much oil do we have left in this
country ah
this country well our reserves today are
about
27
billion barrels
we have about three percent of world
reserves
but oil reserves are not a
it's not like a bank account people
often think of that it's an economic
concept that depends upon exploration
what we do know is that our recoverable
reserves have been going down
while our demand has been going up and
we have become increasingly dependent on
imports which is quite different
even as late as world war ii in the
united states it's hard to believe
provided 85 percent of the oil that the
allies used in the second world war
roughly how much of the oil that we use
in this country do we produce ourselves
half
what was that 20 years ago uh 20 years
ago or 10 i mean in other words what's
what's been happening to them well
um
five years ago it was a
we produced three quarters of the oil we
used ten years ago we produced half the
oil we use there's been a a move
20 years ago we probably produced about
70 percent of the oil 70 75 percent of
the oil we used i'd have to go back and
look at the specific number
but
we were mostly self-sufficient the
we started though at the end of the
1940s was when we first started to
import some foreign oil
and i then tell the story of how this
became a subject of great contention
involving people like lyndon johnson and
john conley and and sam rayburn
reflecting the interest of domestic
producers who was concerned that this
cheaper foreign oil was coming in and
would basically undercut them in the
market and it was a big political
brouhaha in the 1950s that led to a
quota system that tried to restrict oil
imports to about 12 percent of our total
consumption
where in the united states today is oil
refined and not refined where is it
where is it drilled well the big places
are alaska which provides a quarter of
our total oil supply
texas oklahoma louisiana california's a
major oil producer
new mexico a number of other states but
those are those are the biggies
and how much of our oil do we sell to
others
zip zero
i mean we do i mean we may sort of swap
a little bit at the canadian border and
that sort of thing
but we don't uh we're not we're once we
were the world's number one oil exporter
now we're the world's number one oil
importer
what other countries are big producers
well the other two real biggies are the
soviet union
which produces the number world's number
one producer and the number two producer
currently is saudi arabia
which has pushed up production because
of this crisis and is now producing more
than the united states
and is there any other deposits of oil
around the country around the world that
we don't that we know of but haven't
been drilled
well
in in the book i cite the words of uh
the greatest 19th century american
wildcatter man named john gailey who was
so good at finding oil that they said he
could smell oil and gaily was the one
who said draw drill here for the great
well that became spindle top and opened
the texas oil industry
and gailey said something he said only
dr drill knows for sure
and i'm struck that a few years ago a
number of american oil companies spent
two billion dollars
drilling
a dry hole off the coast of alaska
and meanwhile some of the biggest
discoveries have been made almost by
accident when people thought they
wouldn't
happen
in arabia in the north sea even in
alaska when arko was just about to throw
in the towel and it discovered the north
slope in north yemen more recently so
there's a lot more risk and uncertainty
than people think
but there are a couple of areas that are
considered very prospective and have
been underexplored and they have some
ironies in them one is the soviet union
and we see the door
possibly opening to western capital in
the soviet union
the other and this is quite ironic is
vietnam which since it's been sort of
cut off welfare by the soviets needs to
earn some hard currency
and is offering some of the best terms
in the world to the international
petroleum industry
and a lot of non-us companies are there
but because u.s companies aren't there
because our legislation doesn't allow it
but the vietnamese ironically the same
vietnamese who are against us
would be very desirous of having these
companies there now
when you aren't writing books what do
you do
i run a company called cambridge energy
research associates with my colleagues
prior to that i've been an academic
i taught at the harvard business school
at the kennedy school at harvard
and then
in the early 1980s
established cambridge energy actually
the same year that i decided to write
this book
and what is cambridge energy research
associates we're an independent uh
objective research institute
and our job is to analyze the energy
markets and the politics and economics
that surround them in order to give
decision makers and public sector in the
private sector
an independent view of the forces at
work or the directions they may go and
the issues that are down the line for
instance last
spring we started to do work on the
strategic petroleum reserve and would it
work and and another at the time people
thought this was quite archaic and now
uh it has become a
topic of great importance so we try and
pick up early what are important
questions that are coming down the road
located in cambridge mass cambridge in
paris oslo where we have a group that
focuses on oil transportation and
tankers in california how big is the
company about 60 people with another 20
or so experts who work with us as part
of our network
and is it did it start in 1980 started
really 1982-1983
when i was just winding up
decided to retire from the academic
world take early retirement are you part
owner yes and what kind of people work
in uh in the company they tend to be
people with uh economics background or
uh sort of political economy background
and uh who've maybe had some experience
focusing on energy economics either in a
university or think tank or perhaps in
government or private industry oil
companies your clients clients is really
quite a broad range it includes a lot of
financial institutions banks
institutional investors who manage
pension funds and have to decide what to
allocate companies that produce oil
oil companies
natural gas companies pipelines
some major energy consumers
who you know airlines who are extremely
concerned about what happens to the
price of oil
and
international organizations and federal
government the government has we do have
a dialogue with them
uh this is a broad question but
i think you know why i'm asking it
did you have to pull your punches at all
in this book because of all your clients
no uh i learned something with shattered
piece my first book that when you write
a book it is uh
it really goes on it takes on a life of
its own and it's a very heavy
responsibility because it's going to be
out there year after year whenever
you're doing anything
down the road so i decided early on
to really take the same viewpoint that
we have in
our companies to be objective
and uh
you know really what people are are
subscribers if they don't like our
opinions they don't have to subscribe to
them because we set out and it's very
important we set our own research agenda
in the company in this book i was going
to tell the story as i saw it and
as i understood it and
i spent a lot of work and time to do
that so
i wanted to do it the best way i could
where'd you grow up grew up in
california
what city i grew up in los angeles where
did you go to undergrad i went to yale
studied what
i hesitate to admit this on the air but
actually my my major was english
literature
and my specialty was the 19th century
novel why do you hesitate to admit it
well somehow
it was oil and literature mix i mean but
maybe that's why mark twain is a
character in this book
but uh
you know it was all over i sort of felt
that what i'd written was a victorian
novel in a certain sense rather than a
you know
with lots of characters and people
but i think that did as i look back on
it and i didn't think about it at the
time but i think that educational
background had an impact on how i
approached the story and how i told it
what did you do after you got your
undergraduate degree i had a marshall
scholarship which was a scholarship that
takes you to england
and i went over
did a second group degree in history and
i did a phd in international relations
and history at
cambridge university and that was the
i knew i wanted to write a book in the
origins of the cold war and so i really
began that as my phd thesis and then i
came back to harvard as a
university as a postdoctoral research
fellow
and uh wrote
the book that became shattered peace
which came out in 1977
and then
as it start really started teaching at
harvard and started
around that same time i'd started i
started a couple of years earlier
actually focusing on energy questions
and
then was asked to join the faculty at
harvard business school and that led up
to
doing the next book energy future
when did you get uh can you think back
when you got your first interest in
energy oil
i think
i can remember how it developed which
was as i was finishing
shattered piece
you know doing history can often be um
i would say a depressing subject because
it actually can be it's a very exciting
subject an important subject but you
look you look at the what ifs of history
why did certain things happen and i was
very preoccupied
why did the 1930s take the course they
did why did 35 million people die in the
second world war in europe in 15 or 20
million people in asia
and it led me back to the question of
the political meaning of economic growth
and the failure of economic growth in
the 20s and the 30s and how that set the
stage for this rapacious uh
aggression that culminated in this
terrible war for which such a heavy
price was paid
and
i dealt at the end of shattered peace
with how although people expected a
depression or recession after world war
ii instead we had very strong economic
growth and really the beginning of the
growth that carried us through the 50s
and the 60s and so i came away with a
very strong sense about the political
significance of economic growth and that
it's dangerous for democratic
institutions not to have a growing
economy because people start fighting
and the system becomes subject and
vulnerable to demagogues and so forth
and as i looked around sort of put poked
my head up as i was finishing shattered
piece
there was this energy crisis and that
seemed to me as i looked and thought
about it
to pose the
kind of question is this is this going
to be the series of events that robs us
of this economic growth on which our
political system
has come to depend and without which
things can get ugly
and by that point i had a postdoctoral
grant which gave me some flexibility and
i just started really on my own
investigating and writing about these
things i'd done a lot of writing for the
new york times magazine and sort of
international issues and they asked me
to do an article way back in
1974 about well what can we do about
what can the u.s do about opec at that
point opec had come out of nowhere and
was this fearsome ogre which seemed to
have seized control of the world economy
and so all of that is what led me
to to do this
and then once
i started writing more and more and then
that's when the business schools asked
saw what i was doing and said would you
come over and join us and since kind of
what i knew to do was to do books i mean
that's the way my mind thought
i said well let's do this book called
that became energy future and that was a
team project and
it came out in 1979 at the right time
longhand he actually wrote this book out
in longhand why
i believe
strongly in this age of word process i
use a word processor i certainly do and
but i believe that word processors are
too easy
they're too facile and it leads to
verbosity and it doesn't lead to as
tight taught controlled writing as you
need the posture is wrong
and this was a 2500 page manuscript if
i'd written on a word process there
probably would have been 4 000. i was
talking with a newspaper reporter the
other day with whom i was doing an
interview about the book he was saying
that's true that when he does things on
a word processor you tend to quote the
whole quote rather than take the essence
of the quote
and so i found that
i had a much greater sense of control
i also like to be in a relaxed posture
when i write i mean because i it's
almost uh we'll call it a trance but
just a flow like a runner's high and i
find sort of slumped out on a chair or
stretched out on a couch with a yellow
legal pad and
sort of sketching things out
like that i have this it just flows more
than sort of sitting there at a word
processor so what i would do is i'd
write it longhand and then i would put
it into a word processor and that would
be the process of editing it
but
i think that
almost everybody uses the word processor
now and one of my favorite
thoughts about that is people say how
great word processes are is that you can
move paragraphs around but that suggests
the number one problem that's faced by
writing in america today is paragraphs
in the wrong place and actually there
are a lot of other problems in writing
too and just moving paragraphs doesn't
solve them so i'm not an anti-word
processor but from a point of view of
control and style
by longhand just gives i felt a more
graceful result
two kids of yours born during the seven
years at the
writing this book yes
yes uh one five and a half or he just
reminded me yesterday five and three
quarters
in anticipation of his birthday now
they're three and a half and uh
they're both excited about the book uh
my daughter asked me the other day we
were driving the car actually over the
christmas holidays
and suddenly hit this little voice in
the back seat saying
daddy why did you write the prize
that's sort of a stoplight i turn around
and say that's a very good question
rebecca
i'm not sure i can give you an answer
immediately
i will think about it
out of mouth of babes
why seven years
uh a couple of reasons one is that
was in the middle at the same time of
developing a business
uh and i think uh
i should say that
there were real costs in terms of
you know working all the time in the
diversion of interest
but the value of it was that i i learned
i think two things one is i learned
to see things from the inside of the oil
industry how people inside see it which
is quite different than it would look
say to a tenured professor who's quite
distant from it a tendency to assume
people have a tendency to assume that
people other people actually know what
they're doing and that's not exactly the
case i mean people are reacting more
short term
secondly uh i think i learned uh
what risk means you know that you don't
you have to make decisions every day and
you don't know what the outcome will be
and you hope that more than 50 of them
are good and that's this is a book
about an industry that's very
entrepreneurial and was helpful in a
sense to be entrepreneurial to
understand it so that was one reason
the other reason is i think that
books of this dimension end up just
taking a long time
i was looking at a reading an article in
the new york times yesterday about
biographers where somebody talked took
10 years to do this biography
ronald steele who wrote the wonderful
wonderful biography of walter littman i
remember clearly
ronald saying when he was starting the
book that he was going to do it in two
years and it took about 10 years
there's a sort of how do you master the
subject
how do you
there's always another archive there are
always more people to interview your
viewpoint changes
and so i think that these big books if
you look at them these big sort of
narrative histories that people love to
sort of sit there and read and you know
sort of really get into
there's some
[Music]
hidden spring that forces you to spend
seven eight ten years when you're
absolutely sure at the beginning that
you're going to do it in two or three
years i have a friend who's just
starting a big biography
now and
he said he's going to do it in two years
and i said
good luck
what changed in your thinking over those
seven years
i think i came to understand more the
cycles of the oil industry in the
relation of politics
that uh
i think that was one thing that uh i
learned a lot that if i had known in
1979 would have changed my perspective i
had known the story that i tell in the
book about what happened in iran between
1951 and 1954
the duel between muhammad mosudeg and
avril harriman
the
instead of the ayatollah khomeini as it
was the ayatollah khashoggi and his
threats to kill harriman and so forth i
would have um
seen
events in 1979 differently i would have
had a perspective and
i think that the book provides
that kind of perspective so
uh so cycles politics
the importance of the history obviously
the oil industry went from when i
started the book it was still you know
oil was price was way up there and it
looked like the opec imperium was still
going to continue we had the price
collapse and we had the price come back
again somewhat
so a lot of turmoil in there
uh
all of that during this sort of period i
mean i was watching
the history one of the challenges
was to tell
the story of the history
so that i dealt with recent events with
the same dispassionate tone
an objectivity and distance that i dealt
with events at the turn of the century
and that was a one of the narrative
challenges that i faced
at what point in your writing did the
kuwait story come
into this
well
we're talking about the invasion by iraq
well here's what happened about 16 17
months ago i came to the conclusion that
i needed to finish the book
one of the reasons was that my editor
was periodically calling up me from
simon stern screaming at me to finish
the book
and uh there was a scent i was getting
letters saying come on come on you know
enough is enough
i felt that the oil market was beginning
to resemble more and more the early
1970s and i thought this oil market was
heading for a crisis and in the spring
i testified
at a senate energy committee
i think maybe the only person there was
c-span
and
it was an empty room but saying you know
this is a crisis-prone market it's
looking like the early 70s and one of
the senators domenici i think it was
that sometime within the next decade i'm
sure we're going to be back in this room
it's going to be crowded and it was
within seven months that happened
but so i had the sense i had to get it
finished and actually the big challenge
was the cutting
then
you know having read so many books
that are overtaken by events so quickly
i was asking myself
scratching my head doing the same thing
we do in our business well what's down
the road
that we're not seeing that's going to
then that what's the next surprise
and there were a lot of events starting
in february in developments that made me
think that whatever it was going to be
it was going to be iraq's bid for
hegemony in world oil
i didn't know the invasion of kuwait
so
in may and june i rewrote chapter 34 and
the epilogue to focus on iraq the bath
party saddam hussein
uh i
finished the epilogue which was hard to
do i remember uh
boy we had friends stayed with us when i
was writing and i would get up at four
in the morning and just try and
think it through
with four points
the oil market is looking like the early
70s
keep your eye on saddam hussein
watch the soviet union
and energy and the environment is this
big political problem we have in the
united states finished it on july 28th
went off to england to
read my galleys away from telephones
relaxed we'd taken a little house
and on uh
august 2nd at about 5 or 5 30 in the
morning was awakened by a phone call
from our paris office saying well what
do we can do about the kuwait situation
i groggily found out what the kuwait
situation was i had come to the
conclusion two days before that iraq was
going to do what seemed to be the
rational thing seize the contested oil
field and seize the island since the
world couldn't spell either of them
anyway
no one would notice that was a rational
thing
and uh
i
you know had not like most people or
virtually everybody including the
kuwaitis did not think that there would
be an invasion
but as a consequence of the changes i'd
made in the late spring and early summer
i didn't have very much rewriting to do
i did some
in the prologue and in the epilogue and
and but
amazing thing was how things pointed in
that direction and the big challenge
actually became the production process
and normally a book with 32 pages of
photographs that looks like this takes
about 10 or 11 months to produce
and they
simon schuster did a miraculous job of
producing it in about three months i
virtually moved in
to
their offices in rockefeller center
and uh i remember the managing editor
there said that she was going to get
caught for me so i could live in the
conference room but there was so much
that had to be
done people don't unders know the
manufacturing process how complicated it
is with a book but it
it's a it's a it's like a federal case
to get it done
how's the book selling
it's selling at what they tell me is
best seller levels uh it's on regional
bestseller list
number three in long island it's the
best seller in houston it's in san
francisco
it's had
sort of the quadruple crown it's had
front page reviews the number one
reviews and the four major sunday book
review sections
which doesn't happen very often it's had
one fact wonderful reviews
and
has tremendous
momentum and uh
you know i'm i'm doing
the thing that i've forgotten what it
was like to do with the the traditional
book tour is you're communicating with
people around the nation
but i think that the uh expectation is
that this
well let me see how the publisher sees
it they see it as two things one
narrative history that you know people
who like barbara tuchman or david
mcculloch this is the type of thing that
they
type a book that they would read even if
there was no kuwait crisis because it's
a grand epic story and the other is that
it does provide the framework that
otherwise just is not there for the
strategic significance and role of oil
right up to this crisis which seemed to
hit the nation
you know so unexpectedly
there have been a lot of accusations
that we hear on this network and call in
shows from the audience let me just
start with a couple of them and see if
you can help us
that the oil companies are
shafting america
yes
well
my
basic view is that the shadow of john d
rockefeller from the late 19th century
uh is cast itself all the way to the end
of the 20th century because
you know when the prices go up to the
gas pump we all get mad and we all get
very suspicious
and i'm sure that at the fringes there
was a certain degree of
price gouging by some people but on
balance you had a massive disruption of
world oil in the same scale as
1973 1979 the price went up it's now
come down
at least before the january 15th
deadline
and
in fact one of the striking things was
correcting for inflation
quite amazed because i had to do it for
the book to say well when did we have
the cheapest oil prices since the second
world war
and i would have thought it was the
1960s because i remember all these gas
wars but it turned out that actually if
you took the gasoline prices 1960s in
today's dollar would be about a dollar
fifty the cheapest gasoline prices were
actually 1988 through 1990
but i don't think anything i mean
you know that
i mean this is a geopolitical crisis
that involves iraq and military force
and i think the companies are sitting
there there's a picture of a bunch of
company executives being sworn in by
scoop jackson in 1974 and i
think that the oil companies have
learned the lesson that everything they
do is going to be investigated and
subpoenaed and
you know that
they know that the troubles in store for
them if they try and cut corners or
engage in wholesale gouging
in italy they pay something like five
dollars a gallon for gas in japan four
dollars
in germany three something why do we
only pay a dollar thirty three cents
well our gasoline tax is about ten
percent of the um gasoline tax uh in
western europe
those countries have looked to gasoline
tax as a way to
raise revenues
we regard a gasoline tax as a an
occasion for a boston tea party
what it means is uh that the
gasoline tax i mean is a very small
component and yet you think well
i mean part of what's going on with all
these troops out there and all the cost
of that
is because of
gasoline oil supplies shouldn't that
be rolled into the price and somehow
perhaps shouldn't some of the
environmental considerations be rolled
into the price
that
you know you don't have very many
congressmen wanting to stand up on
c-span or in the congress and say let's
raise the gasoline tax but a somewhat
higher gasoline tax would at least
reflect the realities of
what it costs uh
our society
the so-called social costs that are not
reflected in uh
the actual price of the physical
commodity
what do you say to those callers that
suggest that the oil companies and the
automobile manufacturers are in cahoots
well from my study of the history the
oil companies in the automobile the oil
companies and automobile companies are
often quite at odds
uh when i was doing uh energy future
i came through a case that had been done
at the harvard business school through
some of the papers and internal memos
done by one of the big automobile makers
in the early 1970s
when the oil market was tightening and
they were just dismissing that as oil
company propaganda i think
there are two different sets sets of
view
when the callers say that there's this
collusion do they say collusion to do
what
to either keep the price up or to keep
cars running on gasoline and that's why
we don't have battery-operated
automobiles
um
of course the automobile makers like to
see they don't like high gasoline prices
they like to see low gasoline prices i
mean that's uh
probably and they're interested of
course it depends upon their fleet mix
whether they have efficient or
non-efficient cars
these questions about alternative fuels
i think is it's a significant question
and i think that we
need to have a significant alternative
fuels campaign be it an electric car or
alternative fuels there's a movement
towards
operating fleets for instance on natural
gas
i think the the primary issue has been
objective
economics and acceptance in the
marketplace and reaching a critical mass
as a country we have tens and tens and
tens and tens of billions of dollars
invested in a system that enables you to
get in your car and drive across the
country and fill up at all these
different places and never worry about
supplies
and
now we're going to talk about building
another system to run parallel to that
or are we going to talk about something
that i think is very important making
our automobiles continue to make them
more energy efficient and either core
course involves tens and tens of
billions of dollars and then you have
the question well what's going to happen
to the economics brazil did a big
alcohol fuels campaign
and converted a lot of vehicles and now
they'd like to get out of it because
it's just really not very economic
so
it's a you know it's
this isn't i mean i think we should be
pushing that way but it's not because a
few people have said we're not going to
do it but it's a it's the dynamics of
the
existing economic system
and and technical system that we have
what about the charge that george bush
former cia director
former oil man is protecting the oil
companies in the middle east
well i think the answer to that i keep
hearing that too is that
it ain't american oil
the oil companies were thrown out by the
middle 1970s
iraq owns its oil kuwait and zithers oil
and saudi arabia owns its oil
i think that
i do have the story in there about
bush's visit to saudi arabia in 1986
when prices were very low and he said
very low prices would decimate the
american oil industry and it turns out
that's true we lost 2 million barrels a
day of production since 1986
which is equivalent it's actually larger
than what kuwait or venezuela were
producing on the eve of the crisis it's
as though we lost a major oil exporting
country
my own sense
and this is said you know just as an
observer of the historical record
that
bush does believe that there's a strong
relationship between oil and america's
security and prosperity he's a pragmatic
politician
i don't think that he would not only
risk
almost half a million american troops
in the gulf but let's face it completely
put his own presidency at peril
if he didn't believe that the stakes
were real i mean he's not an ideological
politician but the other thing is i
think that
because he is from the oil industry as
you point out he is from texas
i think he's probably gone out of his
way not to use the o word
as i recollect and i think somebody felt
like sort of going back to look this up
but jimmy carter had no hesitation about
talking about oil in 1980 when he
promulgated
the carter doctrine
which uh
his
national security advisers
big new brzezinski wrote committed
america committed the united states to
the protection of the persian gulf
security they use the old word a lot
then but there's a i think a hesitation
to use it now for the reasons we've been
talking about just showed a picture of
james schlesinger and your
acknowledgments of the book you give him
a particular praise for cooperating with
you how come he gave me a lot of time
you know some people i'd interviewed for
a few hours
he just gave me lots and lots of hours
and
helped me to be
precise you know when you're doing a
book like this
it's so easy to
you know for little mistakes to creep in
and uh and he helped in that regard
right what do you say to somebody who
says they're listening and say aha
that's the reason daniel jurgen wrote
the book the way he did i mean what
about the influence of jim schlesinger's
way of thinking on you
well i think schlesinger was one voice
out of about i don't know 80 or 90
he certainly has a strong voice and many
other people have their own strong voice
but you know what i have my own strong
voice too and
and uh my convictions what sessinger was
helpful for was understanding specific
events
that happened when he was on on the
watch in the 1973 crisis and the 1979
crisis
that he was there and he was part of and
made and privy to some of the key
decisions but i talked to a lot of
decision makers
around the world
and the viewpoint in the book and the
themes of the book are very definitely
mine and the book had been
shaped long before i
i talked to
mr schlesinger
since you uh
you
went back to the beginning of all this
and in the history of oil
this may sound like a naive question but
who has been fair
in the world who's had something to say
about the future well who is not who's
ripped us off do you mean uh
either
yeah or governments or you know would
you say in in history that uh
for instance that the shah of iran was a
rip-off artist i mean you see what i'm
getting at who do you think
yeah in history you know treated this
issue right reminds me of the old uh mad
magazine cartoon about the long ranger
where tonto and long range are writing
you know all these different directions
they're surrounded by indians and long
rangers says
well kimo sabe we're surrounded and
tanto says what do you mean
i mean are you speaking as somebody from
the northeast as a consumer or somebody
from houston or
i guess
the average american citizen
as they look at this thing of oil which
is controlled so much about what this
country does
which politician has
used it for their own personal gain
their own political gain which one has
been in your opinion the fairest and and
treated the whole issue in a way that
served us the best i think that
generally people
uh deal with oil
it's a very interesting question you
pose
and one
interestingly enough that i haven't
thought through because
i wasn't trying to make moral judgments
i was trying to sort of tell the story
i suppose in general people have pursued
their own interests
and uh if their interests and sometimes
they've interpreted their interest in
short-term ways take the sha of iran
for him i think oil was ultimately
fool's gold
if he was a price hawk in 1973
if he hadn't pushed up the price of oil
perhaps we would not have had this huge
influx of money into his country that so
destabilized the society
that it led to the eruption that that
caused the toppled the peacock throne
perhaps his son would be sitting on that
throne today so i think his pushing up
the price
and the hubris and arrogance that went
with it
did himself in
i think in general
we've had a pretty good deal
in this country in the post-wars years
of suburbanization of oil we've had for
the most part readily available oil and
a couple times when we've had
disruptions it's been cheap
i mean you know
no one likes the price that goes up
anytime the price goes up in los angeles
my mother calls me and you know and
complains
you know and uh and my wife does the
same thing i mean everybody does but
when you look in terms of inflation and
so forth and other things
we've had a pretty good deal we've been
able to get on with our lives and go
where we want when we want
but i don't think that we should think
that anybody
has done this out of a favor for us or
because they like us i think that
nations pursue their interests and
politicians do and sometimes people
suffer from an illness that was first
diagnosed in the 1870s called oil on the
brain when they think
that oil gives unlimited power it gives
great power
but it also
can be
quite
damaging will it be our downfall
i think it's a form of
weakness and what i see in the question
that i focus on
looking at the rest of this decade in
the aftermath of this crisis is how do
we as a country
resolve these environmental values that
have become such a strong part
of our culture
that you know what i always think of we
had an earth day last april and somebody
was 25 day 25 years old at earth day in
1990 was five years old in 1970 they
grew up
with uh with earth day
and environmental values and i think
there's a real gulf
between people one generation another
understanding their respective values
but these values are very strong
and at the same time we do have energy
requirements
that
that power our civilization we have
become a lot more energy efficient i
just did the numbers looked at them
again before i came on this show we're
about 25 percent more energy efficient
today than we were in 1975
but we are going to face these tough
choices
how do we produce do we want to be a
nation that increasingly imports our
energy or not uh do
how do we
safeguard the environmental values that
are so strong
and i don't and i really end the book on
a question mark because i see
that we do it through guerrilla warfare
and the political process and endless
litigation and i just keep thinking
there must be some way we can get a
balance on these issues
a national
consensus as to uh how we want to what
kind of energy future we want as well as
what kind of environmental future one of
the things you do is spend a lot of time
on previous wars and individuals who got
us into war
and let me read you one cut line on the
picture uh adolf hitler made oil central
to his plans for conquest in world war
ii
his ill-conceived invasion of the soviet
union was halted just short of the rich
oil resources
of the caucus
hitler is an interesting case early on
even before i started the book i came
across a line in a book
written
by a german saying that and written in
the 1930s saying that hitler had learned
the lessons from general ludendorff who
was one of the two commander the
two commanders of the german army the
first world war
about
how
the lack of oil at the end of the first
world war had been one of the main
factors that led to germany's surrender
and hitler and i quote some of the
people who worked with him was obsessed
with oil he knew the history of all the
oil fields
he knew their production rates
in the middle of uh
in the aftermath of the battle
stalingrad in the middle of the night at
four am the morning calls general von
monstein his commander in the eastern
front and gives him a lecture about the
significance of oil in world politics
and screams about you know my quarter my
generals don't understand anything about
economics
he was very obsessed with oil and i
begin that chapter
talking about how ig farben came to him
and the beginning of hitler's interest
in the synthetic fuels
which
making oil from coal in which hitler
really committed himself to in 1936 as
part of his girding for war
and
in attacking the soviet union he was
motivated by his hatred of the slavs his
hatred of communism but his two
objectives one was moscow and the other
were those oil fields around baku where
just recently we've seen by ethnic
civil war
and
he was driving for that
in the
north africa general ramo basically fell
apart his campaign because he ran out of
oil he wrote to his wife shortage of
petrol it's enough to make one weep
and
when
so hitler was very focused on this as a
question because you
you couldn't have motorized warfare and
that's what rommel said you couldn't
it's all meaningless
and in 1944
in may
the allied air forces finally began to
attack the german synthetic fuel plants
which were providing about half of
germany's total fuel supply
and
all of its aviation fuel
that day albert shapiro the overlord of
the german war economy later said he
said on that day the technological war
was decided
on that day the allied generals had
finally stopped committing as he put it
absurdities
and that was a critical moment
and
that was the germans ultimately couldn't
get their airplanes into the air even
though they developed jets which would
have been formidable
weapons against us they didn't have the
fuel to fly them
so
uh in some ways you can say that the
circum world war
some ways not by any by all means not it
was what was an oil war oil was
important to objectives to the contact
of the war to strategy and to its
outcome another cut line in 1941 the
militarist general tojo
used the american oil embargo as the
reason to attack pearl harbor
yes and you've got a picture here i'll
show where he was tried to commit
suicide in 1945 yes at the end of the
road
and ironically
the the americans wanted to save him so
he could be put on trial and the great
threat was not that they couldn't find a
doctor but they couldn't find an
ambulance with gasoline in it when they
finally did
japan was very focused on the oil fields
of southeast asia was seen as essential
to its military strength it didn't want
to depend upon the united states we
supplied 80 of japan's oil
as japan launched on its grand campaign
to dominate east asia with its
co-prosperity sphere
americans said why are we providing the
weapons
the machines the tools for japanese
aggression so we cut off steel we cut
off various machinery and finally
after they invaded vietnam in 1941 with
no other way to express displeasure we
cut off oil and that's what sort of
finally tilted the japanese as to their
timing of their attack into southeast
asia rather than going towards siberia
which they were also thinking about
and also made the decision to attack
pearl harbor which was to protect the
flank
as i tell the story in and particularly
in terms of admiral yamamoto's thinking
who thought it up to protect their flank
as they went uh to the oil fields of
southeast asia and the whole southeast
asian campaign
you know that other little picture there
of the the models is a picture that i
think most people have never seen that
the japanese made a a little harbor a
toy pearl harbor and that was battleship
row where they uh
practiced the and thought through the
tactics that they would use
you don't have much time left and i want
to ask you about more politicians you
mentioned london johnson earlier
lyndon johnson in oil what's the story
well the story is that lyndon johnson
was from an oil state he was very close
to the independent oil men
and
he represented their viewpoints and
interests in congress and sought to
protect the depletion allowance and
other factors and fought and played a
key role in fighting for quotas
to limit the amount of foreign oil
coming into the united states
has politics
have personal politics in other words
the need to raise money on the part of
politicians led to
what you consider to be bad oil policy
anywhere
um
i think that you know i i would say the
place to look probably if you're
thinking about these questions is
watergate and certainly in the public
mind watergate and the oil crisis and
all that coming together and illegal
campaign contributions
uh
which came from the oil companies some
oil companies as well as from a lot of
other companies all of that i think in
the public's mind really tied together
sort of oil money
the notion of oil money
shaping american politics
i think these days when these battles
come up
the battles that exist are over these
environmental issues
and these seesaw back and forth
where you have environmental groups
pitted against
energy companies on really critical
arguments about
what type of development we will or
won't have in the country
and
you know i see the merit and the
rationale on both sides that's why i
think these are such tough questions
that we're going to
be facing once the heat of this
immediate crisis is over
do you have strong personal views
yourself about all this in other words
do you take strong positions politically
i tend not to i see that the the role
that i have is to is to be objective and
independent to provide a framework for
understanding uh these uh contentious
and uh and often acrimonious questions
have you ever been involved in politics
not in any significant way i mean i when
i uh
early on i was i mean there was a period
when i i organized my first political
club when i was nine years old called
the pint-sized democrats
and uh
i wrote some speeches uh
for a few different candidates but like
15 or 20 years ago but
haven't really
had direct political involvement and
you know maintain a dialogue with
republicans and democrats
on these issues more as a as an
independent expert rather than as an
advocate for specific positions does one
or the other party tend to have a better
policy toward oil or the environment in
your opinion well i think it oscillates
back and forth
that depends on the issue what i would
like to see and i pray that we see
coming out of this crisis is that we can
have an ecumenical energy policy so we
don't repeat those kind of energy wars
that i described there that we had in
the 1970s which are so debilitating and
leave us worse off so in my view it
should be some from column a and some
from column b and recognize that we're a
diversified country with diverse
interests rather than a kind of
sectarian energy approach what's your
next book
uh first to recover from this uh i have
about three ideas in mind but i'm still
playing with them and i think that first
is my number one priority is to catch up
on my sleep
and as you toured around and talk to
people about this book of yours what's
the question they most often ask you
you get a lot of questions about uh this
because of this crisis
about the significance of uh imported
oil to the united states uh struggling
to understand what are the stakes uh
what is this about is it about five
cents at the pump what's the biggest
misunderstanding that the average person
has about oil well i think one is that a
lot of people still don't know that we
import half of our oil
uh
and the other i think is that they do
think that you know it's a bunch of uh
you know the oil companies are over
there
running the show when the oil companies
were thrown out i mean we're in a
different
era
i find i'll tell you what i find and
i was on a lot of recall in radio shows
the other day i found there's a lot of
raw emotion
on both sides of
on this question
a lot of anger and as well as confusion
there's a lot about this book we didn't
talk about and in the 60 seconds we have
left what's what are some of your
favorite things that people will learn
if they read this
i think they'll learn the degree to
which
american society has been
shaped
by the ability of
to have oil my favorite statistic in the
whole book has nothing to do with the
price of oil it has to do with the fact
that 40 percent of american marriages
are proposed in automobiles which i take
is the
one of the great signposts of the
hydrocarbon society that oil has made
possible i can't leave you though but
ask you what's the trend on that up or
down
on proposals i haven't i haven't seen it
i haven't seen it over time i imagine as
cars the number of cars have gone up
probably the trend has been upward as
well this is what the book looks like in
your bookstores it's called the prize
by daniel jurgen our guest for the last
hour thank you for joining us thank you
[Music]
join us next week on book notes for a
conversation with syndicated columnist
carl rowan in his recent memoir breaking
barriers mr rowan shares his
observations on american politics and
race relations gained from his
first-hand experience in government and
journalism over the last fifty years
that's next time on book notes
and if you would like a printed
transcript of this week's program send
five dollars to tape writer incorporated
box 885 lincolnshire illinois 60069
do